[Musik]
was ist eine volkspartei wie viel
zustimmung muss eine partei vom
wahlabend mit nach hause bringen damit
sie sich volkspartei nennen darf
genügen die volksparteien eigentlich
ihren eigenen ansprüchen noch und fallen
volksparteien langsam aus der zeit
fragen über fragen hochaktuell dazu wenn
sie an den letzten weise und tag denken
rekordverluste was machen union und spd
falsch die zuschauer das thema dafür nix
runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
ein arbeiter ist bei uns sie leben
arbeitet in berlin als freie
journalistin und autorin für die
süddeutsche zeitung schreiben über
generationen jungen alter proteste und
auch über bürgerbeteiligung axel
wallrabenstein kommunikationsberater
geschäftsführer eine pr-agentur sie
haben unter anderem auch schon die cdu
beraten professor norbert bolz medien
und kommunikations theoretiker an der
technischen universität berlin und
albrecht von lucke
politikwissenschaftler redakteur der
monatszeitschrift blätter für deutsche
und internationale politik davon locke
hat die spd eigentlich schon ihre
entlassungsurkunde als volkspartei
bekommen
die hat sie ja vielleicht sogar
schleichen schon seit einigen jahren
erworben und das was die spd wohl als
den größten gefürchtet hat war der fall
unter 20 prozent also gewissermaßen die
endgültige absage an die vorstellung
dass sie noch einmal in die regionen
dessen kommen kann was eine volkspartei
meines erachtens im kern ausmacht
nämlich und das haben wir glaube ich
immer unterschätzt
einerseits natürlich das inhaltliche
eine bevölkerung breite art ab zu feiern
und zu vereinigen aber auf der anderen
seite ein struktur konservatives element
fast nämlich die fähigkeit eine
regierung auch an zu führen und dieses
momentum ist der spd schon seit der
spaltung der linkspartei des abgangs der
linkspartei abhanden gekommen und das
gleiche droht jetzt der union und das
macht die momentan meine ich so
historische lage aus derweil haben stand
die union nähert sich tatsächlich der 30
prozent marke
ist das der beginn einer politischen
schwindsucht wird sie der spd bald auf
ihrem weg folgen
also ich glaube wir müssen über die
frage was volkspartei ist auch noch mal
ein bisschen diskutieren also auch eine
definition
ich würde das jetzt nicht als
schwindsucht bezeichnen wenn man sich
mal anschaut
2005 hatten union und fdp zusammen 45
prozent jetzt haben union und fdp
zusammen knapp 44 prozent also ich meine
es geht nicht darum ergebnisse schön zu
reden aber es geht darum auch mal ein
bisschen die kirche im dorf zu lassen
insgesamt glaube ich aber schon das war
auch schon seit längerer zeit meine
meinung dass die zeit der volksparteien
so wie wir sie definieren wie wir sie
kennen vorbei ist wir werden andere
strukturen haben wir werden kleinere
parteien haben das ist eine anpassung an
die gesamtgesellschaft wie wir das auch
in anderen bereichen erleben zu glauben
dass bei einer gesellschaft bei einer
wirtschaft wird eine ökonomie die sich
völlig verändert wir ihn ja auch immer
von disruption die parteien system oder
das parteiensystem so bleibt wie wir es
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg ist einfach
absolut ein jegliches hat seine zeit
alles vorabend unter dem himmel hat
seine stunde und besagt das alte
testament geht die zeit der
volksparteien gerade vorüber
also auf jeden fall da schließe ich mich
an die zeit der volksparteien wie mir
sie gekannt haben
wir sehen schon seit einigen jahren dass
ich menschen zunehmend eher punktuell
engagieren er themenbezogen engagieren
lieber die bürgerinitiative als die
partei lieber das einzelinteresse als
das große ganze
das ist natürlich für volksparteien
insbesondere schwer da noch zu sagen
okay wo habe ich jetzt die klammer zum
beispiel als spd wo ich den akademiker
und den arbeiter zusammenbringen gebäude
sind die volksparteien zu wenig
anpassungsfähig zu wenig geschmeidig zu
wenig innovativ
ganz im gegenteil ich glaube das ist
gerade ihr identitätsproblem dass sie
ihr traditionelles bild an ihrer eigenen
stammwähler nicht mehr vermitteln können
aus höchst unterschiedlichen gründen
bei der spd das ist sicher die
traurigste alle geschichten ist es ganz
schlicht so dass sie in dem augenblick
als sie den mut gefasst hat mit gerhard
schröder tatsächlich ihr grundprogramm
an eine veränderte welt anzupassen mit
der agenda 2010 ein traumatisch
produziert hat für alle traditionellen
spd wähler oder für fast alle
traditionellen spd wähler ein trauma das
auch heute noch nicht überwunden ist und
das eine sogwirkung bis zum heutigen tag
außer der cdu natürlich eine ganz andere
geschichte
die eng damit zusammen hängt aber eben
anders gelagert ist und das weiß
mittlerweile jeder
das im grunde angela merkel mehr oder
mit einem alleingang nicht nur die
partei die cdu übernommen hat sondern
dass sie eben auch alle wesentlichen
programmpunkte der konkurrierenden
parteien okkupiert hat also die
sozialdemokratisierung der cdu aber
mittlerweile auch grüne partei die
grünen partei kann sich im grunde bei
der cdu auch wiederfinden
es gibt mittlerweile einige prominente
grünen grünen politiker die gerade zu
beten für angela merkel und ihre politik
es ist buchstäblich so und das bedeutet
eben dass auch die traditionellen cdu
wähler in dieser merkel cdu sich eben
nicht mehr wiederfinden können und diese
beiden identitätsprobleme führen denke
ich zu den erosionsprozess die wir
beobachtet haben ja hier schon hat schon
fast jeder oder jede eingefordert die
sollten definieren was ist eigentlich
eine volkspartei
man könnte es ja quantitativ machen bei
wie viel prozent fängt eine volkspartei
an das oder qualitativ was macht eine
volkspartei aus essen aussuchen
ich will vielleicht mal eins direkt
aufnehmen es macht ja manchmal durchaus
auch sinn
die volkspartei von der funktion in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik eher zu
definieren und das wäre dann ein
bisschen vielleicht
kontrast zu dem was er wir haben strenge
gesagt hat gucken wir uns das ja dass
sie als referenz gebracht haben 2005
2009 war der erste große verlust
tatsächlich genau wie sie gesagt haben
der großen koalition
in dem jahr haben tatsächlich cdu und
spd hochgradig verloren die spd lag bei
23 prozent die cdu knapp 334 so sie
kommen beide zusammen aber immer noch 57
der entscheidende unterschied zu der
gegenwärtigen situation ist aber der die
cdu kann ihre klassische rolle der
volkspartei in koalition mit der fdp
erfüllen wir bleiben gewissermaßen im
funktions modus der alten bundesrepublik
und das ist das was im gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt verloren geht seit adenauer
die entscheidende zäsur beginnt mit
adenauer entscheidet sich 1949 gerade
wissen das nicht zur großen koalition
das war damals eine ganz heikle
situation er hatte die umstrittenen hoch
geschnitten er hat eine stimme mehrheit
sagt ich wähle das bürgerliche lager er
konsolidiert anschließend durch die
einbeziehung der kleinen rechten stützen
die die cdu und gewinnt dann knapp acht
jahre später die absolute mehrheit
dieses prinzip dass die bundesrepublik
mit zwei funktionstüchtigen
volksparteien in der lage war jeweils
ein geschlossenes lager zu versammeln
69 dann der wechsel zu willy brandt
damit also gewissermaßen die erste
sozial-liberale koalition dieses
funktionsprinzip endet in diesem jahr
und das ist der große unterschied auch
zu ihrem datum es macht nicht entstehen
entscheiden die kripo die prozente sind
nicht der entscheidende punkt aber die
tatsache dass wir in diesem jahr völlig
wegkommen von dem prinzip der
möglichkeit einer zweierkoalition weil
die letzte mögliche koalition nämlich
die koalition von spd und cdu auch nicht
mehr zustande kommt
das iwes herzlich wissen aber dass eine
funktion müssen es die funktions die
haben uns immer so daran gewöhnt die
funktion ein stück weit zu
vernachlässigen dass diese funktions
erfüllung die volkspartei geleistet hat
die stabilität der republik zu
gewährleisten das ist ein enormer wert
und wir werden es den nächsten wochen
noch erleben dass diese absurde
jamaika-koalition die regelrecht jetzt
erzwungen werden soll allergrößte
schwierigkeiten nach sehr wahrscheinlich
erzwungen wird die frage war ja kann man
das quantifizieren also in größenordnung
ausdrücken muss eine volkspartei auch
immer eine regierung führen können
oder geht es tatsächlich um die anmutung
um die zusammensetzung um die ansprache
das können ja auch kleinere parteien
schaffen
nochmal für sprechen dass man auch sagen
kann also was ist die funktion nach
innen von erfolgs partei ich hätte das
gerade gesagt so die interessen
splittern sich auf die menschen
organisieren sich entlang bestimmter
themen eine volkspartei ist für mich
auch eine partei die verschiedenen
interessen verschiedene themen und
verschiedene milieus zusammenbringen
kann und so entsteht dann im besten fall
eben eben eine hohe prozentzahl bei
wahlen aber wichtiger ist für mich noch
dass eine volkspartei anders als eine
partei die sich so einen andern sehr
bestimmtes milieu richtet wie zum
beispiel die grünen oder wie die fdp
eben verschiedene milieus in sich
versammeln kann was sich nicht
widerspricht mit dem also das heißt
nicht unbedingt klientel partei das ist
ein bisschen mehr dabei rabenstein ihre
definition können sie ergänzen oder
sehen sie das völlig abend also um das
erst noch mal zu noch mal darauf
einzugehen wir hatten ja gerade in
nordrhein westfalen noch mal die
möglichkeit dass es nur zwei
konstellation gegeben hat also das ist
jetzt nicht völlig sozusagen aus der
droht ja also wie eine ebene gibt es
durchaus noch weiter geht der analyse
ist schon richtig und ich sehe das
ähnlich ich glaube auch dass wir einfach
zu einer anderen definition kommen
müssen warum soll nicht parteien die 20
oder 25 prozent haben volksparteien sein
wir reden immer sie haben das ja auch
gemacht so in dieser nachkriegs
terminologie
damals war die welt noch in ordnung es
gab drei parteien das hat sich alles
irgendwie geklärt da war die welt aber
auch eine andere
ich meine wir haben volkswagen hat in
deutschland volkswagen marktanteil von
17 prozent die volksbanken haben
marktanteil von 23 prozent warum soll
eine partei mit 25 oder 30 prozent nicht
volkspartei sein also ich weiß gar nicht
warum wir darüber diskutieren natürlich
gibt es dann keine zweier konstellation
mehr sondern es gibt dann zweier dreier
vierer konstellation vielleicht auch 5er
konstellation das heißt es werden andere
leute gebraucht das werden nicht mehr
sozusagen parteivorsitzende führe wenn
man so will gebraucht sondern es werden
gute manager gebraucht die koalition
bilden
die bündnisse organisieren die
vielleicht dann auch in
legislaturperioden auseinanderfallen die
bündnisse wieder neu zusammen schmieden
aber ich habe das vorhin schon gesagt in
der wirtschaft nennen wir das auch
oftmals disruption warum soll das in der
politik völlig andere sein wir können
doch nicht an parteien system festhalten
die wiese nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
hatten während sich die komplette welt
die wirtschaft die gesellschaft
verändert das ist es ja vielleicht auch
jede partei in irgendeiner weise
interessant mal zu überlegen was mit
volkspartei gemeint war und was heute
offenbar nicht mehr mit wirklich keine
lehren können und was mal gemeint war
war doch und es gab eben immer nur zwei
volksparteien die spd und die cdu
es gibt ein linkes lager und es gibt ein
rechtes lager es gibt die
bürgerlich-konservativen es gibt auf der
anderen seite die reformistischen kräfte
und beide parteien war mussten stark
genug sein um dann mit irgendeiner
anderen klientel partei zusammen eine
regierung zu bilden
und genau das ist jetzt nicht mehr
möglich deshalb kann man bei einer 20
prozent partei wie der spd nicht mehr
sein das ist nun folgt also jeder hat
irgendwie volkspartei wenn sie eine
große anzahl oder einigermaßen große
anzahl von stimmen hat ist der
integrationsfaktor den eine partei
ausüben kann einen maßstab absolut also
ich würde auch sagen im volkspartei dem
mord steckt doch eigentlich schon dass
es nach einer wahl eine überzeugende
repräsentations kraft dieser partei für
das ganze volk geben kann also dass man
sich zwar streitet aber das ist
prinzipiell doch so sein muss das mal
die sozialdemokraten und auch von
anderer seite dann mal wieder die
christdemokraten das ganze volk
repräsentieren und das ist eben bei
einer klientel partei prinzipiell nicht
der fall also bei es gibt ja auch die
ein punkt parteien wenden uns an die
piraten in die grünen ursprünglich auch
die fdp ist eine gewisse weise früher
auch eine klientel partei gewesen die
linke erst recht bei diesen parteien
wäre sinnlos von volkspartei zu reden
während man doch bei cdu und spd immer
auch diesen anspruch hatte wenn da ein
kanzler gewählt wird ist er tatsächlich
der kanzler des ganzen volkes und nicht
irgendeiner interessen kommen also
möglicherweise hat sich die definition
von volkspartei im laufe der jahrzehnte
auch etwas verselbständigt jetzt schauen
die parteien ja nicht unbedingt auf
ihren auf ihre integrations kraft in
erster linie sondern auch das
zweitstimmenergebnis und empfinden
daneben dass ihr nimbus als volkspartei
schwindet was haben das haben wir im
untertitel des der sendung was haben
union was am spd eigentlich falsch
gemacht dass sie zumindest im
numerischen also im zahlenmäßigen
bereich so sehr an zustimmung in der
bevölkerung verlieren also meiner
meinung nach ist ein großes problem
tatsächlich ein inhaltliches dass wenn
ich jetzt als etwas jüngerer mensch
schaue ich jetzt nicht so sehr auf die
parteien wie sie unter adenauer waren
sondern überlegt mir naja was sagen die
mir zum beispiel auch über die zukunft
was sagen die mir über die gegenwart und
ich finde
bei der spd ist das schon relativ früh
eingetreten dass man nicht mehr das
gefühl hatte die lösungen die sie
anbieten passen unbedingt zudem wie sich
die welt entwickelt also das progressive
fehlte zum beispiel man sagt spd ist
eine arbeiterpartei aber wie hat sich
die arbeitswelt verändert durch die
digitalisierung zum beispiel unter
welchen dingen leiden jüngere leute
heute da kommt von der spd kam dann
nicht nicht die antwort die sich zum
beispiel meine kommilitonen und ich also
gehört otto genau dass man damals
generation praktikum
da fühlten sich viele sehr allein
gelassen bei der cdu denke ich hat das
noch länger funktioniert aber da ist
natürlich auch die frage selbst
konservative können nicht sagen
konservativ sein bedeutet irgendwie 100
jahre dasselbe also auch eine idee wie
eine konservative politik aussehen kann
muss heute anders aussehen als sie das
unter adenauer war und damit meine ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt dass man alle
positionen über bord werfen soll sondern
dass man sich eben schon zum beispiel
sein sein kernthema familie nimmt und
dann aber sieht okay mit dem was wir
jahrelang als familie verstanden haben
können viele nicht mehr viel anfangen
was ist denn dann das neue familien wenn
man jetzt über jahrzehnte den den
rückgang der zustimmung für diese
parteien
beachtet er ist ja geht ja auch zurück
für union und für spd
liegt das aber rabenstein am
persönlichen am politischen unvermögen
der parteien also sozusagen an einem
professionellen defizit oder ist das
eigentlich ein gesellschaftlicher
wandlungsprozess der kaum aufzuhalten
ist ich würde das zweite sagen also es
ist ein wandel wandlungsprozess der so
nicht aufzuhalten ist und deswegen
glaube ich auch dass wir volksparteien
einfach anders definieren müssen und
nicht mehr sagen können das sind
parteien die wirklich für das ganze volk
stehen diese bindungskräfte haben
dafür hat sich die gesellschaft viel zu
sehr verändert sondern werden kleinere
parteien haben wir werden auch mehr
klientel parteien haben wie wir das in
der gesamten gesellschaft aussehen und
die müssen sich halt zusammenraufen das
wird eine andere art von politik sein
auf die wir uns dann auch einlassen
müssen wir sehen dass wir auch in vielen
anderen ländern wo parteien auf einmal
aus dem boden schießen und nach einigen
jahren auch wieder verschwinden wir sind
ja in deutschland da in einem in einer
situation die extrem also wenn extreme
sicherheit haben wo sich kaum etwas
verändert hat über die letzten
jahrzehnte
und ich glaube wir sind jetzt einfach
auf dem weg dass wir merken hier bewegt
sich etwas hier tut sich etwas und ich
sehe das gar nicht negativ ich sehe das
eher positiv weil ich glaube dass die
parteien jetzt auch in dieser
veränderung ihr diesen
gesellschaftlichen trends folgen wir
haben ja länder wo wir zwei große
parteien haben beispielsweise in den usa
da gibt es die republikaner und die
demokraten
ich will das nicht von volksparteien
reden aber was kommt denn da ein
ergebnissen raus also die weiteren
parteien ja eine andere funktion in der
andere stück schwach aber wir haben wir
haben dort eine struktur mit zwei jahren
von der band sich die gesellschaft immer
weiter kulturell vor allen dingen
fragmentiert wenn sie nicht mehr diese
eine große erzählung gibt diese
lagerfeuer parteien dann müsste es ja
als wenn man auf die spitze treibt
eigentlich so viele parteien geben wie
es lebensentwürfe gibt bei den im besten
sinne und das ist natürlich eine absurde
vorstellung
und deswegen kann ich auch mit herrn
wallrabenstein vorschreibung
beschreibung gar nichts anfangen er
alleine die übertragung und es
vielleicht im wirtschaftlichen positiv
zu denken disrupt diskutieren
nennen wir es mit der schöpferischen
zerstörung
ist natürlich auf das politische
übertragen in dieser sehr einfache weise
ein 1 1 h kiri vorgang wir müssen uns
doch bewusst machen dass neue dieser
republik und deshalb laden aber gar
nichts zu tun das ist ein
strukturprinzip war die vorstellung dass
wir tatsächlich habe man sagt man so
schön gesagt das volk in der mehrzahl
definieren es gibt das volk immer nur
eine mehrzahl in der tat nämlich als
zwei volksparteien und diese beiden
volksparteien haben über 70 jahre die
stabilität dieser republik gewährleistet
was ein großer unterschied zur weimarer
zeit war da haben wir genau das phänomen
nämlich gehabt ohne 5 prozent verweisen
und das ist eine recht und damit absolut
und deswegen ist für die vorstellung
jetzt machen was auch man ähnlich
destruktiv wie in der ökonomie eine
ziemlich erstaunliche und eine eine eine
provokative ist ja wohl eine rolle wie
wollen sie es denn vorher sind wir
sollten jetzt nicht in betracht wenn sie
noch interaktionen jetzt hier sagen dass
wir helfen ihnen heiß weltfremd daher
habe ich dann ist auch er fährt nicht
nur zwei dinge unterscheiden
es gibt eine normative vorstellung die
man erstmal unterscheiden muss von einer
des kreativen so und die normative
vorstellung wie volksparteien beschaffen
sein könnten und wie sie im besten falle
auch wirklich stärke erlangen müssten
eine breite abzudecken ist noch nicht
abzuschätzen
wir kennen doch alle die großen defizite
unserer gegenwärtigen volksparteien
beispielsweise der spd die eine reine
funktionärs partei der sich zuspitzenden
der sozialwissenschaftlichen
studienabgänger lehrer hier geboren sind
die nicht mehr die breite erfasst der
arbeiter der arbeitslosen et cetera das
war in früheren zeiten völlig anders man
muss die vorstellungen die das ist der
große klientel ist mal eine million
partei durchaus ist ja ein gewachsenes
arbeiter- liches milieu so das war
damals natürlich leichter organisiert in
der spd aber heute wäre natürlich
trotzdem der anspruch aufrecht zu
erhalten das duo aus verschiedenen das
aus verschiedenen breiten dieser
gesellschaft nach wie vor eine
vertretung möglich
ich will das noch mal sagen ich deswegen
bin ich so so scharf vielleicht oder so
kontrovers dass sie sagen wir schenken
das alles leichtfertig ab aber gar nicht
n 1 1 also so im experimentierfeld und
sagen jetzt versuchen wir was neues
das halte ich für ein großes experiment
was eine bisher gelungene demokratie die
wir schon in den nächsten monaten da
sind prophezeit in einem schweren
übergang erleben werden mit diesen drei
parteien die sich ja schon eine vier
parteien die sich hin
wir regen zu einer völlig neuen
konfiguration zusammenraufen müssen
da werden wir schon sex perspektive
experiment erleben was machst du es
spannend wissen sie das ist ein schönes
wort
er war rabenstein spannend ist für die
politik in der lage in der wir uns
gegenwärtig befinden
nein über gleich mal ganz kurz
es geht ja wir über die renaissance von
volksparteien reden ob das noch möglich
ist oder ob das nicht weiter in die
konstruktiven weise in diesem
patentierten bereich weiterentwickelt
wenn wir haben jetzt mehrere definition
definitions versuche von volksparteien
gehört herr bolz ist die fdp die jetzt
noch im bundestag ist verdient die auch
den nahen volkspartei wenn man sich mal
die wählergruppen anschaut das geht ja
eigentlich nicht unerheblichen teil
durch das wissen an den wählergruppen
das ist deshalb nicht sinnvoll selbst
wenn sie erheblich höhere prozentzahl
noch erreicht hätte
weil sie sich ja nur durch negation
definiert also die afg ist im
wesentlichen die merkel muss weg partei
und wenn merkel weg wäre denke ich
könnte sich die partei auch nicht auf
diesem niveau halten auf das im moment
erreicht hat also ich glaube nicht dass
die die afd war in dieser wahl die
einzig wirkliche oppositionspartei sie
hatte nur eben das problem dass sie
nicht integrieren konnte all die
unzufriedenen die degut sich abgewendet
haben vom braunen rand dieser partei das
war und ist ihr ganz großes problem dass
sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht lösen kann
aber das ist das thema das ich gerne
ihre diagnosen entgegen stellen würde
vor allen dingen ihrer ich glaube zwar
so ist das elegant und chic formuliert
und sehr zukunftsträchtig und trendy
aber das lenkt ein bisschen ihre
diagnose lenkt ein bisschen von dem viel
brutaleren sachverhalt ab dass die
beiden großen parteien cdu und spd sich
selbst herunter gewirtschaftet haben
also dass sie in unglaublichen
vertrauensverlust eingefahren haben
passt die spd betrifft habe ich die
andeutung mit der agenda 2010 ja schon
gemacht
die meisten von uns sich auch würde
sagen das war die richtige entscheidung
von schröder damals aber es ist nicht
angekommen man konnte die resonanz beim
eigenen publikum nicht schaffen bis zum
heutigen tag nicht und bei der cdu ist
es ganz ähnlich die cdu hat eine geniale
opportunisten an der spitze
die sehr sehr elegant lange lange jahre
uns geführt hat durch alle möglichen
unbilden der weltpolitik
aber die mit ein paar fundamentalen
emotional geladenen groß entscheidungen
im grunde ihre eigene klientel gezwungen
hat zu entscheiden
ich mache das mit oder es ist für mich
die katastrophe also ihnen gehören nicht
mehr in diese partei und das sind beides
riesengroße krisen die dazu geführt
haben dass diese parteien wahnsinnig
verloren haben gucken sie doch die
wahlergebnisse an
es gibt nur zwei gewinner und zwei
verlierer die beiden verlierer geben die
cdu und die spd das sind die beiden
parteien die eben nicht sich geäußert
haben zu den großen themen die die leute
bewegt haben und das war auch in der
öffentlichkeit so sie haben beide im
grunde gesagt die flüchtlinge sind gar
kein problem
sicherheit ist auch gar kein problem
sondern lass uns über was anderes nun
soziale gerechtigkeit digitalisierung
diesel skandal
das hat keinen menschen interessiert
würde sind die beiden parteien die das
thema angepackt haben die afg mit aller
gewalt mit aller kraft und die fdp im
übrigen auch man hat ja sogar gemunkelt
es gebe da ähnlichkeiten zwischen der
aus der der flüchtlingspolitik der der
fdp und der der afd
diesen abend gewonnen das heißt die
parteien die das wird die wirklichen
sorgen und ängste der leute in
irgendeiner weise ernst genommen haben
die haben sich in diesen wahlen
durchgesetzt und die das geleugnet haben
dass da überhaupt probleme sind die
haben durch aber sie haben ja zumindest
ist das so wahnsinnig und sie reden von
durchgesetzt also das würde ich jetzt
mal so überhaupt nicht beschreiben
sondern auch wenn die großen parteien
verloren haben
trotzdem ist die union regierungsfähig
und es wird der unterricht in der
entsprechende regierung gebildet werden
können wenn du das behalten wir das
machen das heute dass sie reden alles
schlecht wenn das versicherte das was
sie sagen stimmen würde hätte er die csu
und super ergebnis haben müssen weil sie
am ende ja sich um die themen sicherheit
und so weiter gekümmert hat also ich
meine radeln nicht er hat natürlich da
genau das also insofern was sie sagen
stimmt einfach nicht und ich muss auch
mit ich sagen dieses runter geräte also
das damit dass die volksparteien kleiner
werden dass das ganze jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen fragiler wird das du
sozusagen als der untergang des
abendlandes ist ich sehe das überhaupt
nicht machen sie doch mal ganz das ist
auch mal über die aktuelle situation
reden in der wir uns befinden sie
beschreiben als in den letzten 15 jahren
alles völlig den bach runtergegangen wir
leben im land mit der niedrigsten
arbeitslosigkeit wir haben
wirtschaftswachstum
wir haben seit vier jahren keine keine
schulden mehr wir haben nie mehr in
bildung in wissenschaft und forschung
investieren
natürlich können sie jetzt sagen ich
trete ja ja ja aber das wir so tun als
würde sozusagen das abendland und sie
kann das ja wort gesetzliche zweiten
blick
das wäre sonst frage jetzt mal an der
stelle haben die volksparteien das wohl
spd als braucht cdu wirklich und cdu und
csu wirklich so schlecht gewirtschaftet
wenn man das mal über einen längeren
zeitraum betrachtet in dem sinne von
dass sie politische themen aufgenommen
haben dass sie vielleicht sogar die die
überlegt haben was interessiert die
leute was was bewegt sie ist das
wirklich so weit weg von der bevölkerung
dass man sie jetzt sagt das ist kein das
sind keine parteien mehr die meine die
mich repräsentieren denen ich mich
anvertrauen würde also ich denke ich
hatte ja vorher auch eigentlich fast
eine ähnliche diagnose gestellt zu sagen
okay ist zersplittert alles immer mehr
dass es eher so der zustand was wir
jetzt ganz stark gemerkt haben auch bei
der bei der süddeutschen zeitung haben
wir so ein paar formate gemacht wir viel
mit lasern auch gesprochen haben ist mir
sehr stark aufgefallen dass die
sozusagen das bedürfnis nach einer einer
großen idee nach nach werten nach einer
klammer die alles zusammenhält wieder er
wächst in meiner empfindung die
volksparteien aber nicht die genauen
nicht bedient wurde und da gebe ich
ihnen durchaus recht also wir haben uns
natürlich auch viel mit dieser mit der
flüchtlingsfrage beschäftigt ich würde
jetzt nicht gehen
die diagnose teilen dass die fdp
deswegen gewonnen hat ich glaube das war
er weil sie eine ganz bestimmte
zielgruppe sehr gut angesprochen hat
jungen urban
ich glaube nicht dass das
flüchtlingsthema da so entscheidend war
aber es war tatsächlich ein sehr
wichtiges thema einfach deswegen weil es
dabei um identität gehen und mit
identität haben sich beide volksparteien
so lange ich mich erinnern kann dann
nicht mehr so sehr beschäftigt und was
sie auch zum beispiel über die spd
gesagt haben früher hat die noch dass
das eigentliche milieu angesprochen also
die spd hatte ja schon immer mehrere
milieus sie hatte immer die die arbeiter
als milieu aber sie hatte auch immer so
ein bisschen so ein akademisches mio
also mein vater erzählt mir heute noch
wie er als schüler vor den fabriktoren
stand und versucht hat die
arbeiterschaft sozusagen zu motivieren
sich in der spd zu engagieren oder
ähnliches und da gab es damals auch
schon konflikte aber es gab halt eine
klammer nach allem was was mir auch
erzählt wird ich war ja nicht dabei dass
zum beispiel unter willy brandt ganz
stark das thema war aufstieg durch
bildung und bildung war so ein thema
damit können sowohl die akademika was
anfangen als auch dann die die arbeiter
die denken okay dadurch können meine
kinder was erreichen
das war
zum beispiel so eine klammer war das
aber dass die frage die analyse ist
vollkommen richtig frage nicht
entscheiden sollten sie darauf dass
erfolge wie adenauer willy brandt kohl
schröder dass die genau mit diesem mit
dieser mit einer erzählung oder mit
einem groß thema gearbeitet haben um
damit dann auch erfolg zu haben
absolut und es war natürlich auch eine
andere strukturen mann hatte ganz andere
bindungskräfte wie sich auch gesagt
haben
die spd als arbeiterpartei die union als
partei in der mann war wenn man in der
kirche aktiv war
aber die zeiten haben sich halt völlig
verändert ich meine wir haben ja auch
nicht mehr wie damals zwei fernsehsender
wo sie sich dann abends 20 oder 25
millionen länder menschen sozusagen am
lagerfeuer treffen wetten dass gucken
und am nächsten tag alle drüber reden
diese zeiten sind vorbei und so ist es
genauso auch mit den volksparteien
es geht mir nicht darum zu sagen dass
das alles schlecht ist ich sage nur ist
wird sich verändern und es hat überhaupt
keinen sinn diesen alten zeiten
hinterher zu trauern gelassen wir müssen
sie suchen jetzt wir müssen jetzt damit
umgehen dass wir andere strukturen haben
werden und wir müssen das positiv
begleiten müssen sehen wie wir damit
gute ergebnisse haben daher darf ich
ganz gut zu der frage die frage noch
weil er dafür
sie haben gerade gesagt sechs parteien
waren dafür verantwortlich oder haben
sichergestellt eine große politische
stabilität in den ersten jahrzehnten der
bundesrepublik gehört für sie
volkspartei und demokratie unauflösbar
zusammen aber so lud in diesem falle für
unsere ich sag es mal für die republik
ich sage es mal am konkreten deutschen
beispiel rabenstein sie sind ja nun
berater der union ich könnte auch gleich
kommt eine hoffende konkrete frage der
ehemaligen ohne direkte frage ob sie
danach wir haben bisher kein anderes
gelungenes deutsches modell der
demokratie da müssten sie sonst weit
graben und wir hatten bis 1949 können
das ist das bisher gelungen das ist eben
toll und deswegen würde ich sagen da
sollte man nicht so lax und so und sagen
die kriegen was neues ich sag ich mal
deswegen sagt bisher hatten wir dieses
modell und dieses modell hat
funktioniert und in der tat ist der
große chaos und das große problem beider
volksparteien und die spd scheint mir
schon ein stück weit daran gescheitert
dass sie die identitätsfrage übrigens
unter weise mit der agenda 2010 verloren
die an denen die agenda 2010 war in
vielen fällen meine sachen so wie es
auch falsch weil sie interessanterweise
gerade diese aufstiegs erzählung nicht
mehr geleistet hat sie hat im gegenteil
eine drohkulisse aufgebaut sie hat er
eine spaltung des landes bewirkt sie hat
in der tat arbeitsplätze geschaffen
aber bei großer fragmentierung der
gesellschaft bei quasi eine auflösung
der klassischen arbeitsverhältnisse die
wir jetzt als eine gespaltene
gesellschaft eben in niedriglohnsektoren
und klassischer einige hochgradige waren
übrigens auch ein tiefen boden
geschaffen hat für die spätere für den
afc zustrom vieles von dem was wir heute
erleben im osten beispielsweise in
peripheren und und prekären
arbeitsverhältnissen ist eine grundlage
warum auch die afg stark werden konnte
das gleiche problem ihre partei die cdu
hatte am steuer steht genau vor der
frage und das ist die frage die sie
ihren werden sich bald mit ihren
freunden stellen müssen ist die
identitätsfrage für uns schon derartig
gelaufen dass die afb
das gleiche phänomen darstellt die
linkspartei für die spd die große frage
für die cdu die nicht die nächsten vier
jahre wird sein ist unsere identität so
stark und stark genug dass wir wieder
eine erzählung erzählen können
die uns diese 13 prozent wieder zurück
führt in die cdu damit fangen die bayern
jetzt an und das ist die entscheidende
zahl glaube ich ein kleine kleinen
differenz zwischen den beiden
die spd hat ein anderes verhältnis zu
dieser großen erzählung als die cdu die
spd braucht sie und ohne sie ist sie gar
nichts und die die große erzählung der
genau wie sie es geschildert haben der
spd war immer auch eine des fortschritts
und des aufstiegs und dazu eine ganz
kurze erinnerung ich weiß nicht wie
lange es her ist nicht allzu lange
da kam gabriel auf den gedanken einen
begriff wieder ins spiel zu bringen der
seit ewigkeiten nicht mehr diskutiert
wurde nicht nur in der spd sondern
deutschen politik überhaupt nehme ich
den begriff fortschritt und man hat ihn
sofort zurückgepfiffen hat gesagt das
geht nicht mit diesem begriff kannst du
hier nicht antreten dass damit können
wir keine politik machen aber genau das
ist das problem
die spd war damit verknüpft mit dem
fortschritt mit dem aufstehen also wie
sie das geschildert haben buchstäblich
war das so dass man wenn ich für sich
selber dann für die eigenen kinder ein
fortschritt
projekt entwickeln konnte und das mit
dem reformismus in der spd sehr sehr gut
haben uns sehr gut der cdu was immer an
das meines erachtens ich will nicht
sagen sie haben nie etwas zu erzählen
gehabt aber sie mussten es nicht denn
sie hatten eigentlich ständig hält und
vor allen dingen waren sie als
bürgerliche hatten sie einen natürlichen
opportunismus des erfolgs also die der
wirtschaftliche erfolg wird automatisch
steht der bürgerlichkeit zu gute dass
ich ein bisschen erfolge der 27 ist und
hat sich dazu gegenüber der spd lässt
sich daraus erklären dass die cdu die
csu so lange den bundeskanzler die
bundeskanzlerin gestellt haben und die
spd entsprechend ganz gut
er hat sich auch immer der opposition
viel wohler gefühlt als die union jemals
das ist weiter dramatisch war und das
macht man in der natürlichen der
opposition viel viel konsequenter als
wenn man diese ewigen kompromisse
irgendeiner unterschiedlich da bestimmen
ja durchaus zu auch in vielen in vielen
dingen die sie analysieren trotzdem
glaube ich nicht daran dass wir nicht
nur die volksparteien in der form wie
wir sie kennen
in der bisherigen form wie wir sie
kennen in zukunft reden werden deswegen
glaube ich auch ist es also ich glaube
nicht daran dass man sozusagen das die
linke irgendwann wieder zur spd kommt
dass die grünen sich dann irgendwann
wieder einreihen aber das sozusagen auch
dass das das sozusagen auch eine partei
rechts von der von der cdu sich dann ein
rein wir dafür hat sich die gesellschaft
viel zu sehr verändert und deswegen
glaube ich muss man einfach strukturell
auf diese fragen anderer antworten geben
und nichts glauben dass alles wieder so
werden kann wie es einmal war da ich
vielleicht nicht passiert frage noch
einmal ganz kurz aus sicht jemanden
sehen der jünger ist der diese schöne
zeiten diese herrliche der volksparteien
nicht mehr selbst miterlebt hat ist das
weil ich habe ja auch die frage gestellt
wie hängen volksparteien herkömmlicher
art mit der demokratie in der
demokratische stabilität zusammen ist
das aus ihrer sicht zwingend nötig dass
es diese volksparteien wie bisher weiter
gibt oder ist etwas mehr politische
promiskuität die zukunft auch erträglich
und gefährdet nicht die stabilität bei
uns ich denke ich würde mir sehr
wünschen dass es in zukunft auch noch
volksparteien gibt weil ich eben glaube
dass sie schon einen großen wert darin
haben auch verschiedene leute zusammen
zu bringen in sich im kleinen rahmen
deswegen finde ich sie sehr sehr wichtig
also ich finde tatsächlich gar nicht so
sehr das problem wie viele parteien sind
jetzt in der koalition das würde ich gar
nicht so so kritisch sehen ich denke da
kann man sich schon schon arrangieren
aber zum beispiel aus sicht der jungen
generation ist es im moment sehr
problematisch dass es einfach sehr viel
mehr ältere menschen gibt als jüngere
das heißt man kann als junger mensch nie
im leben sagen wir über stimmen die
jetzt einfach mal dass das wird in
zukunft nicht passieren da wäre zum
beispiel eine volksparteien ort wo sich
leute verschiedener generationen treffen
zusammen setzen und sagen okay wie
können wir das machen genauso finde ich
es so über verschiedene milieus hinweg
also wenn man jetzt zum beispiel auch
wahlpartys ist es ist ein totaler
unterschied ob man auf einer wahlparty
der fdp und der grünen ist wo es ein
sehr homogenes mühe gibt oder ob auf
einer wahlparty der spd ist wo es muss
sehr viele unterschiedliche menschen
gibt die dadurch auch in die politik
integriert werden und wir haben ja so
über einen punkt noch gar nicht so
ausführlich geredet ist dass viele leute
generell der politik so misstrauen dass
sie dass sie grundsätzlich alles in
zweifel stellen was politiker überhaupt
machen und das war ja auch immer eine
funktion von volksparteien eben auch
leute in die politik zu integrieren
bewusst zu integrieren die vielleicht
nicht zur gesellschaftlichen elite
gehören oder nicht zur bildungs elite
gehören das heißt wie sich dieses
misstrauen von gesprächen führt aber ja
eigentlich wenn ich jetzt die letzten
monate und jahre betrachte gar nicht mal
so sehr zur resignation sondern es hat
ja die politisierung eigentlich sogar
noch befördert woran liegt das dass man
sagt also eigentlich bin ich mit dem
unzufrieden das stört mich hinten und
vorne aber die gesellschaft ist so
politisiert wie schon lange nicht mehr
das ist richtig ich hoffe dass das nicht
einfach nur steckenpferd reiten ist wenn
ich sage das hat ein bisschen was mit
den neuen medien zu tun
das hat etwas zu tun mit einem neuen
strukturwandel der öffentlichkeit
also dass die leute auch spüren dass sie
plötzlich was früher undenkbar war in
der lage sind ihren unmut sinnvoll zu
organisieren wenn man früher über irgend
etwas unglücklich war die startbahn west
wird ausgebaut oder sonst irgendetwas
hat man sich getroffen plakate gemalt
irgendwo in der volkshochschule und ist
fürs rathaus gezogen
das macht heute kein mensch mehr sondern
heute organisiert man sich im netz
man bildet communitys den gemeinsames
interesse haben wird sofort klug beraten
und ist so eine schlagkräftige truppe
die sehr sehr gut informiert und
ausgebildet ist und das sind natürlich
möglichkeiten die nicht nur die jungen
nutzen die natürlich vor allen dingen
aber wenn man mal hinguckt wer in den
einzelnen communitys so ist das geht
mittlerweile quer durch die
altersgruppen hindurch und die leute
spüren dass das sie jetzt die
möglichkeit haben zu wort zu kommen sich
zu artikulieren und dass sie damit
erstens die klassischen massenmedien
verunsichern aber auch die politik
verursacht und sich jetzt als die
etablierte politik sondern da setze ich
meine ganze hoffnung rein deshalb denke
ich gar nicht an den untergang des
abendlands ganz im gegenteil ich glaube
wir haben es in zukunft damit zu tun
dass die öffentlichkeit struktur selber
sich verändern oder schon verändert
haben so lud und dass die leute wie soll
man sagen die politik mehr oder minder
auch vor sich hertreiben werden mit
ihren interessen diese immer besser
selbst organisieren können das heißt
aber mobilisieren auf kosten der politik
würde ich so nicht unbedingt sagen ich
würde auch durchaus da in dem fall auch
mal die negativen seiten sehen dies
natürlich auch mit sich bringt in vielen
zynischen kommentaren usw
die wir natürlich auch finden und auch
mit mit mit hass und angriffen
aber was sie beschrieben haben finde ich
auch das ist ein wichtiger aspekt dass
leute sich selbst organisieren können
aber es widerspricht ja auch im grunde
genommen
der art wie volksparteien organisiert
sind also wie man da widersprechen sich
ein bisschen wenn das was ich sage nein
stimmt das ist hier ganz andere
möglichkeiten gibt der partizipation
sich zu äußern sich zu organisieren
dann werden natürlich volksparteien in
der form wie sie wie wir sie bisher
kennen und wie sie bisher organisiert
sind so gar nicht mehr gebraucht was
erhard ausland als politisches
volksparteien als ein politisches
auslaufmodell weil es mit dieser neuen
form der kommunikation nicht mehr
richtig paroli bieten das haben die
piraten richter zeitweilig so
vorgestellt aber spitze ich war der
erste versuch das regelrecht bizarr ich
finde auch wirklich noch mal an den
begriffen herbold sagte so schön die
werden die politik vor sich her treiben
das ist momentan der falten und übrigens
mit ziemlich atemberaubenden ergebnissen
zum teil einer verhetzung die wir erlebt
haben wenn wir nur an köln denken
beispielsweise wo wir eine kölner
bürgermeisterin fast zu tode gebracht
erlebt haben aufgrund der verhetzung wir
haben parallel öffentlichkeiten zum teil
im netz die sind nicht alle so lieblich
und so schön dass wir uns das nur als
eine unwahrscheinlich progression der
sache vorstellen sollen und jetzt kommt
das besonders ironisch
es regelt sich überhaupt nichts von
selbst wir haben eine parteiendemokratie
und die tatsache dass ist auch ein
beispiel wo man ein bisschen glaube ich
kritischer gegenüber diesen ganzen sich
überall auftuenden neuen bewegung sein
muss wenn wir nicht starke parteien
kriegen und deswegen mein ganz
konservatives petitum wenn wir nicht
starke volksparteien wieder bekommen wo
viel stärkere leute in diese parteien
müssen und wir es uns alle nicht mehr
leisten können dass wir alle der meinung
sind eine schöne tradition zu machen
eine schöne bürgerbewegung zu machen
auch übrigens die jüngere generation gar
nicht die idee hat sie haben es ja auch
zu recht erwähnt gar nicht auf die idee
kommt zu sagen das sind die parteien die
bei uns die republik und die demokratie
ausmachen wenn wir nicht dazu kommen
dann sehe ich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
erwartet hier ist gerade der volkspartei
ja jetzt kommt es ja diese volksparteien
sind aber immer nur so stark da kann man
fast mit gattin förder kommen wie die
gesinnung in der bevölkerung ist die
diese volksparteien auch als solche
begreift und als wichtig waren daraus
den schluss ziehen dass die bevölkerung
diese personen die früher dieser
position und das ist der zu denken da
läuft irgendetwas schief das sind zum
teil auch ekelhafte formen der reaktion
ist ergibt ressentiments und so weiter
es muss anders laufen oder wir müssen
das wieder in richtung der klassischen
parteien landschaft zurück steuern
ich glaube das wird nicht funktionieren
was aber funktionieren könnte und was
funktionieren muss ist stichwortartig
gesagt die digitalisierung der parteien
selber die müssten sich öffnen auf diese
neue öffentlichkeit
die müssen auf sie zugehen und die
mussten intelligent genug sein werden
kommunikations angebot machen zu können
das aufgegriffen wird denn im moment ist
es ja so dass die politik zum thema
digitalisierte welt im grunde nur sagen
kann mehr glasfaserkabel ausleihen was
ja immer gut ist und immer in ordnung
ist aber damit ist das der punkt der
digitalisierung einheitlich gebracht
in den parteien und der politischen
öffentlichkeit vertreten
es ist natürlich schon einiges passiert
eben stichwort seitdem piraten aber man
darf nicht vergessen gerade bei den
beiden volksparteien geht es da an so
grundlegende über jahrzehnte gewachsene
strukturen r
da ist es unheimlich schwer überhaupt
rein zu kommen also mein kollege
christoph wittmann hat lustigerweise
morgen genau zu diesem thema auch ein
artikel in der süddeutschen zeitung
wo es genau um die frage geht das eben
jüngere leute sagen wir ja also das mit
den mit den ortsvereinen das
funktioniert für unsere diversen gründen
nicht zum beispiel bei wir oft umziehen
machen wir vielleicht eher mal eine
vernetzung über themen ja was was
eigentlich jetzt keine besonders
schwierige sache ist rein technisch
gesehen aber es widerspricht natürlich
total den den strukturen auch den
machtstrukturen wie sie in den parteien
im moment entstehen
und überall wo es machtstrukturen gibt
es natürlich jemand der von diesen
machtstrukturen profitiert und die auch
nicht hergeben möchte das heißt aber
diese diese diese machtstrukturen
schaffen wir trotzdem wiederum eine
stabilität weil die entwicklung die
sieger diskutiert haben dass die immer
geringere bedeutung der volksparteien
kommt die würde ja zum beispiel eine
regierungsbildung wie wir sie jetzt
gerade haben und wieder sie eigentlich
kennen nach bundestagswahlen doch
erheblich erschweren
das müssen junge links sein ich glaube
also ich rede ja nicht gegen die
volksparteien ich sage nur dass
volksparteien anders aussehen werden in
zukunft als wir sie bisher kennen das
wird nicht mehr zwei große geben
mehrere parteien geben die sich dann
auch volksparteien nennen das haben wir
ja auch in anderen ländern das haben wir
in holland das haben wir in skandinavien
die länder sind ja nicht weniger
erfolgreichen als wir in der
bundesrepublik deswegen werde ich mich
ein bisschen dagegen zu sagen weil sich
hier strukturen verändern muss jetzt
sozusagen auch die die wirtschaftskraft
und die gesellschaft und alles sozusagen
schaden leiden sondern wir müssen und da
haben sie vollkommen recht wir müssen
über neue möglichkeiten der
partizipation über neue möglichkeiten
der zusammenarbeit über neue
konstellationen reden wie wir das im
gesamtgesellschaftlichen kontext auch
tun und zu glauben dass es sozusagen
wieder so wird wie wir es mal hatten das
wird halt nicht passieren aber das
ehrliche diskussion einfach müsse
sicherlich gerne hören sie sorgen sich
haben die politische stabilität ohne
volksparteien dann gibt es eben nicht
mehr zwei sondern vier volksparteien die
aber diese stabilität wiederherstellen
hätten ich sage ihr gehalt und die
wohnungslosen fahrzeug als bedingung
nein aber die vorstellung der
multiplikation von parteien
gewissermaßen oder das dividieren von
großen volksparteien zu klein ist
regelrecht naiv wir haben bisher die
stabilität die sagen ich halte sie für
ein wäre ich gucke mir viele andere
länder in europa wie hilft man ja das
ist doch eine center eine these ich sage
wir müssen erstmal uns frage was ist ja
nur heran stein sie haben so sehe ich
mich erklären eine realität für nicht
verändert werden es ist momentan ein
großer kampf im gange ein großer kampf
und es wären sie in ihrer union noch
zuallererst erleben ein großer kampf um
die frage können wir die volkspartei
eigenschaft durchaus unter dem versuch
die weder der ard wieder zurück zu
gewinnen können wir die aufrechten das
ist der große kampf in der union die spd
hatten verloren wahrscheinlich aber die
union kann ihn noch nicht preisgeben
das ist glaube ich die große frage
übrigens ein großes pfund hat die union
noch dass der große unterschied
sozialdemokratie die union hat noch das
große glück dass die krise der identität
der union die tatsächlich an einem punkt
inc das plädoyer der union war immer
keine experimente das
sicherheitsversprechen war das kardinal
versprechen der union
und das ist an einer person vor allem
jetzt aufgehängt die das vermeintlich in
der bevölkerung gebrochen hat das angela
merkel wenn es der union gelingt eine
überleitung zu einer anderen figur dazu
ein einer anderen führungsschicht zu
schaffen die sich ablösen kann
von dem bruch des sicherheitsversprechen
durchaus angela merkel nicht kaltstellen
aber das gelingt dann ist die
möglichkeit da dieses diese identität
wieder zu gewährleisten
ich glaube die spd hat da bereits vor
die union kann das schafft und dann ist
das ein stabilitäts garant das hat
nichts damit zu tun da gebe ich ihnen
vollkommen recht die parteien jede
partei ob sie kleiner großes muss wege
finden die alten gewachsenen strukturen
aufzubrechen und bessere leute zu
kriegen ein letztes beispiel 68 das ist
eine referenz thema doch recht
interessant ist waren die volksparteien
alle parteien aber vor allem die
volksparteien so interessant dass
hunderttausend leute der 68er zur spd
gegangen sind und sofort die
modernisierung der union begann wo genau
die nächsten hundert tausend zu sagen
der unterschied ist natürlich dass wir
jetzt eine andere demografische
situation haben also wenn jetzt zum
beispiel die junge generation hier noch
dort ja genau das sind ein paar noch
dass die älteren sind einfach erst mal
mehr also man hat nicht mehr die selbe
bucht gerade noch heftig genügt also es
erlauben die dass die cdu so zeigt die
letzte oder die cdu csu die letzte
bastion von volksparteien ist es das so
kann das hab ich auch da in diesem punkt
stimme ich 100-prozentig zu dass da eine
regeneration chance da ist ich bin bei
der spd ähnlich pessimistisch wie sie
aber bei der cdu gerade weil sie weniger
programmatisches und ballt sich immer
schon opportunistischer war sehe ich
eine große chance sich zu regenerieren
eben wenn merkel in irgendeiner weise
ausschaltet wenn sie es ist buchstäblich
dass merkel muss weg das wäre auch das
heil für die cdu als volkspartei selber
ich kann mir aber dies im moment nicht
vorstellen und auch für die absehbare
nächste zeit nicht und glaube deshalb
dass man weiterhin auf das merkel
projekt setzt auch um den preis wie
gesagt auf der rechten seite weiterhin
erosionsprozess zudem typische 19
sekunden überzogen
das war die frühlingssonne zur
volkspartei ein umfangreiches thema und
dass wir uns auch erhalten bleiben
bleiben sie bei phoenix
[Musik]